brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment hello welcome to the lobby
games most weekly chat sure every
Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific right here on
King spot calm I want to how many of you
in the GMT lands have done goofed this
up and turned up with the wrong time
because of daylight savings monkey me
jiggery I guess we'll find out soon
enough I'm your host Daniel Dwyer Chris
waters is sitting right there it's
important for the Farmers of America
savings time okay the worst it's
complicated just don't don't worry your
pretty little head about and we're
joined today by Kevin fan org reviews
editor for GameSpot calm why did I say
nine spot calm whoa am i right who would
have expected that we posted three nine
ten of israei all of a big chunk bigger
boom big block right one and you wrote
one and I didn't do crap I mean I did
another job mark Walton is over in
daylight savings nan zone at the moment
daylight ways things there you go he
reviewed the definitive edition of Devil
May Cry micro I see double my cry yeah
oh that game is I came at like two and a
half three or two years ago something
like that I like I always felt like that
like so much negative attention on that
game you know yeah like it never got the
credit it deserved I I wanted to enjoy
it and I played it and I realized that
oh this is a game I don't like because I
just suck at these games oh yeah yeah
which was a shame because it was so
stylish it was like just a it was a
gloriously like I wanted to just sit
back and watch somebody else play
anything and everybody else was mad that
it wasn't hard enough oh really yeah wow
I'm really terrible at Kevin you
reviewed already on the blind forest
yeah that's also a tough game is it are
turns out yeah it's pretty hard tell us
about it your review ends up today on
gangster calm last night actually yeah
really yeah the game is amazing yeah you
think it's a man I mean if that game
would have come out last year now it's
always weird because it's early in the
air you don't say oh this is a sure game
of the Year nominee blah blah blah like
you have to be really careful with stuff
like that but I will say if that game
had come out last year that would have
been in my top three really probably
that's how good that's how much I loved
or in the
I didn't see it coming review code comes
on Friday relatively late in the day I'm
like trying to scramble to find an
author yeah I can't find an author so
I'm like oh [ __ ] there goes my weekend
quickly this new which was already we've
already filled with like all this stuff
I have to write from GDC that I still
have to rough and he had to QA my
hotline review which probably took about
a day on its own yeah that was that was
a that was a couple couple days okay but
but this get but so I didn't like I knew
what it was I knew it was a pretty
platformer than was coming to the Xbox
one and also to PC and purple eventually
eventually 60 they say but you know plug
the code in start playing and in ten
minutes I was like oh really
it makes that kind of tears are those
you need to clarify the crocodile tears
no those are those are faked yeah well
they were real there there were real
bits of water coming out of my like
emotional tears because of the constant
emotional content of the game not
because it's an all-day thing like that
why are we why are we showing me being
terrible what you said what you cried
this is when you cried right Oh what I
was trying to get to an area that I
really shouldn't have even gone to
eventually you unlock a leaf parachute
which makes getting through this area we
should so we should clarify this is a in
the sort of Metroidvania style of you
have access to every area but it's
through unlocking various abilities that
you think you become able to do it right
yeah you're watching yourself down yeah
I mean you can do this but you're really
not meant to go through this spot at
this stage but the this is one of my
favorite moves in the game alright so
you you will get back to the crying in a
minute I swear but this is one of my
favorite things that you can do you can
essentially like latch onto a projectile
or certain enemies and then you launch
yourself in one direction and the
projectile on the other mmm and another
thing to city 3 it clearly hard like how
the motive you know usage but is it also
like if you kick it out that way in
there oh yeah that way and there I knew
that thing was there and I still died so
those are the three the back a little
back okay yeah so give us the the
truncated review
or in the blind far is what is it about
it that makes it more exceptional than
other 2d platformer well I mean if it
helps it it has that first impression
right so it's like and I don't want to
give anything specific away but it's a
very emotional like 10 15 minute opening
where where it really sets the stage
with the story and it help and it does
that partially through gameplay in a way
that's really effective and so so it
starts with sort of this melancholy and
then it just starts building and the
thing is it's not just oh I mean the
story itself is pretty straightforward
it's it's really just you know it's you
know we've seen it in games a million
times oh look it's this this world that
you have to help bring back to life in
certain ways but but it helps that the
characters that you do meet and there
are not very many characters in the game
but the ones that are they're incredibly
expressive they're animated so
beautifully that they they express so
much emotion with just movement
especially because they're not they're
not humans they're they're creatures and
yet they move with this like so much you
know you know intention isn't mean
you're not exactly what happened be
wrong as well I think I've heard that I
don't know if it's I don't know if it's
all hand ER I think in one of the
previews that I have that last year they
said that it wasn't like they liked like
base animations and whatnot but it
wasn't just framing actually everything
is it looks incredible it's it's
absolutely gorgeous but the thing is
it's important to note that it's not
just all about looks I mean it's the
matically consistent it's beautiful and
that beauty goes a long way towards how
you how invested you are in the world
and then what you're doing but it's also
a big part from from the gameplay and
the way it space its metroidvania of
course but it's it's all a fluid single
world there are no loading screens
there's nothing like that you just you
and and the movement feels really good I
mean you just start with like what you
generally start with you just you jump
and then but the regular regular job
just feels really good and then
eventually you can double jump and then
you can wall jump and then you have that
thing that you saw me doing there where
you can film yourself then you have a
parachute and and most of the things you
earn are some kind of way of enhancing
the locomotion and every move feels
really good the controls are just
perfect and
that's a big part of why the you know
why the difficulty is really frustrating
because you always have perfect control
exquisite control over what you're doing
so in this sort of super meatboy vein of
it you know this is difficult but it's
all my fault why I'm for the most part
there's some trial and error bits that
can be a little frustrating where it's
like there's no way you can see coming
what what comes right and that that can
be a little I think that's a legitimate
frustration in a game where there's
simply no way for you to escape
something unless you know it's about to
happen and the game doesn't necessarily
communicate those things until you just
you've died and you have to do it again
and now you know how long has I spent I
mean I bet you if you went through the
story and you know you were decent at
the game I bet you maybe eight hours to
get through I spent about twelve in part
because there were parts where I where I
died a little too much and there were
and in part because I just went off and
explored you know just like much Rivini
guys are little bits and pieces to go
back to and oh here's a here's something
I couldn't get into before and now I can
and they're not to be worth it to do
those explorations totally totally and
in part because I mean this isn't it
wasn't what was there that was really
drawing me it was knowing that it was so
much fun in the getting there it's not a
game that really applies you with
unlockables I mean it does you have
those things you know you you have
passive enhancements that make you you
know more more powerful and and you know
more and more sturdy and stuff like that
but really for me it was about it's so
much fun to move around and it's so
beautiful to look at that going through
these places was always a joy it was
never like oh I have to go and get the
thing it was never a I need to get the
thing it was always going to get the
thing is gonna be so much fun
that was what drew me also what I played
the demo at some event last year what
struck me is how like live and graceful
you are like there's a sense the the
sort of sense of movement it's kind of
silky so there's like this inherent
little pleasure just in the jumping and
in the moving and I think that you know
goes like along would go a long way
towards any kind of backtrack
backing or retracing your steps you know
if it's if it just feels good to move
like that you know becomes way less sort
of a threat of repetition or and I'm a
sucker for for games that do something
special with movement a lot of times
that comes down to because the movement
is so fluid it's why I love for example
Assassin's Creed or why I love journey
but it's also why I enjoy
LittleBigPlanet I do not really know a
little bit there you go but on yeah but
it's also why I love like Gears of War
because even it's not fluid really I
mean it is but it's not it's not haha
you don't have that feeling like you do
an Ori it's it's heavy and and that's
why I love Gears of War but they do
something with movement you feel the
game like you feel the weight whatever
that weight is and that life are heavy
yeah this is one of those games that
does that you feel light and airy you
know at some at some points you just you
know there's a little leaf parachute
that you use to float and sometimes it's
like oh it feels so good to float but
the amount of aftertouch that you get
when you're whether you're in midair
because you've jumped or whether because
you have a leaf or whatever it's the
right amount of aftertouch like it's
just enough that it doesn't feel
ridiculous
but not it's not so much that it feels
ridiculous but not it's enough that it
doesn't feel frustrating to lose your
control once you want to hit the hit the
sky speaking of controls did you play it
on the PC or the Xbox I want to play the
rocksbox one I only sent us code for
that a bunch of people in the comments
we're asking whether or not you'd think
that the keyboard and mouse controls
would work at all it's kind of hard to
you know the size about it I think that
typically a keyboard and mouse is silly
with platformers for the most part I
wouldn't play Super Meat Boy with a
keyboard and mouse I can imagine you can
but I but it sounds silly to me to do it
that way although I'm sure there are
lots of hardcore people that would love
to do that but even even lights easy
platformers like even something like
like Alice madness Returns I'd rather
play with with controllers so it just it
feels right with a controller but
honestly it's fluid enough that who
knows maybe even mouse and keyboard
would be really really excellent too
with this particular setup I don't know
I just have a hard time like yeah why
would you choose it you know when it
comes to you know platformers
taking the controller away doesn't
always make a lot of sense yeah thank
you so much for coming on tell all about
already in the blind forest ad on Xbox
one on PC pretty soon it's technically
tomorrow